So next game against se or se
I have no idea from the USA and I'm still crawling
around in 1950
a long
way, well
yes gehner plays F F4 B3 something
I'll continue to develop normally well let's
see maybe you can get
E5 played here
yes bishop E2  would be normal or something like that, okay,
he just wants to
prevent E5, well, I mean,
black has
n't chosen the most aggressive structure here either
against such a formation,
so you can play safely so well,
I can swap bishop G6 for the one in
the white square or maybe he will
now  somehow start with G4 or something like that, no,
okay, yes, then let's try to swap it,
yes,
pawns, yes, well, of course
that makes it harder for
him to move E4
because F4 is stuck, but he'll probably
arrive with knight E5
You can say what you want, um,
yes,
well, I have to admit that I ca
n't
think of much here, I've just pushed this
position a lot, oh come on, I'm
playing today, I can play for a long time
and then H6 G5 or something like that
shouldn't work at all, but like that  first
the blankets and then straight away H6
G5 t he's at least slow but
I'll definitely pick it up so knight we'll have
one more to E5 well let's go
first king out of the c-file ca
n't stay there forever
so yeah
yeah  good, but
you can just about cover
F7 so knight can come maybe C8 six
times
and maybe I can also move
knight F6 away and
then use F6 to move the knights out of there,
well so the
plan with derruchade doesn't look so stupid
aha  he comes running straight here,
okay, if I play H6 now, what's
coming
then I thought yes, I have to go
back now and then I take F5 and
then here comes something
crazy fe6 HG ef7 or
something like that, well it can't actually
work, well I do  At least I dare to
predict that I won't
lose time so
taken that
yes rook and then knight G6 yes
or or this one next to it and then
knight
G6 crazy yes good but I get E6
also a knight G6
tur8 J you would have to E6  and then
you
got a really good amount of material, so two
corpse figures
for a
rook, so yes, of course, a question like that,
maybe you can also
take that, that
the knight is coming, namely W,
nice here, yes,
that actually looks really nice now,
so, well, good  he wants to go to F7,
well let's put it aside,
so
I underestimated it a bit,
again, this stupid
counterplay isn't so
safe.
Come on, let's move forward here,
so at the moment the whole
thing
still covers that  It could just
be totally crazy what I'm doing here
relies on the
degraders, yes, he has, he already has a
lot of figures then, well,
time has to
play a little bit for us sometimes
Check
Check time
warning
is
okay, well  Well, he will also exceed the time,
so now we would have had the opportunity
to practice mating with three minor pieces,
well, strange
game